you go to Hollywood at 19 and you
auditioned for That 70s Show I guess and
you auditioned for something else yeah
what did you audition for out there
there was some movie there was a boat
show yeah Bo Derek movie that was on
that was on NBC and it was when NBC was
like er and Friends inside was like the
most powerful Network in the world and
you auditioned for both shows and you
got both roles yeah and NBC said okay
make a [__] decision within the day
yeah choose one of them either the boat
Derek show or that 70s yeah the only
thing on Fox at the time was like
Married with Children And The Simpsons
right and it so it was like this like
why what do I I don't know what to do
yeah how do you make that decision
because why go with Fox they barely had
a network at that point I just I I
understood like five kids sitting in a
basement smoking weed like to me that
was like wait hold on that makes sense
although the Bo Derek show didn't make
sense it was about Cowboy Surfers in
Hawaii and I was like that I don't
understand that you would have been a
Cowboy Surfer in Hawaii yeah and even Bo
Derek was a big star and beautiful and
it's on NBC but it was it was the Bonnie
and Terry Turner and Mark Brazil were
the executive producers it was car seat
Warner that had made Roseanne which was
the show that like when I was a kid a
Cosby Show I think Cosby Show they did
Third Rock From the Sun you know that
that group was like had churned out high
quality stuff by the way Bo Derek show
only lasted for six episodes yeah did
you know that I didn't know yeah that's
true I was sure that it wasn't gonna
work but it isn't it amazing that
Hollywood they call like they fly you
out and you audition for two things from
right away I mean nobody gets that kind
of that's crazy it was a it was a crazy
day did it go to your head probably I
don't know yeah I mean it had to be
insane like you're probably like holy
[__] this is easy I had I mean I had a
really good like five years where I was
pretty sure that I was awesome right
because then even even uh I think during
That 70s Show you got Dude where's my
car and that thing made like how much
they made like it's a 13 million dollar
movie they made like 73 million dollars
yeah I had Good Run Of really successful
things that happen back to back to back
and and then you had punked then I took
off I can't imagine I mean it's hard to
sort of self-analyze but I'm pretty sure
I thought I was pretty great right do
you think you pissed a lot of people off
when you thought you were pretty good I
think I was an [__] and you know like
the truth like I I'm sure that I was an
[__] and and I've had like people
retroactively tell me you were an
[__] like even you know it's funny
like when Mila and I started dating she
was like you were an [__] and I was
like I probably was like a real in what
ways were you an [__] seriously I
just think that like you can't when you
when you have that kind of a run of
success it's it's hard to like
self-regulate yeah and you're that young
and you don't really have people telling
you no like I I think like I think
success generally people end up bringing
people around them when they're
successful that just become yes men and
tell you that you're great and even when
you're doing things that are not great
they tell tell you that they're great
and then and then you don't
self-regulate and then you become a jerk